merci beaucoup Auguste bonjour à à
toutes et à tous Tout d'abord
permettez-moi de commencer par des
remerciements des remerciements pour
tous ceux qui ont fait que cette
université cette nouvelle édition de
Guidel est un succès et une réussite
tous ceux qui sont dans l'ombre qui ont
accueilli qui ont
contribué oui merci Jimmy je pense qu'on
peut les
applaudir c'est les retrouvailles et
elles ont été un succès parce que tout
le monde a appter sa pierre autour de
François autour de nos ministres autour
de nos parlementaires de nos sénateurs
de nos députés européens de nos élus
locaux de nos militants nous sommes ceux
qui justement portons des solutions nous
sommes les démocrates nous sommes les
humanistes nous sommes les Européens et
cette session de Guidel l'a encore
démontré par un programme danse par un
programme avec des gens venus d'horizons
divers parce que c'est aussi ce qui qui
nous caractérise dans cette terre
Brotonne cette terre d'ouverture c'est
aussi ça le Mouvement Démocrate c'est
l'ouverture c'est justement cette
volonté d'avancer ensemble et bien
évidemment Auguste tu as parlé des
élections européennes le 9 juin prochain
donc évidemment je vais vous en dire
quelques mots ces élections ça sera
aussi l'occasion de porter notre bilan
parce que nous avons un bilan et je suis
fière justement de le dire aussi devant
notre commissaire parce que il y a
vraiment eu une équipe France au service
de l'Union européenne le bilan de la
transition climatique c'est nous le
bilan de la réindustrialisation en
Europe c'est nous le bilan pour la
régulation face au géants des Numériques
c'est nous le bilan pour promouvoir la
démocratie c'est nous oui Laurence tu as
raison de dire que oui c'est nous c'est
notre action c'est ceux qui croyons en
l'Europe c'est ceux qui cherchons
justement à avancer à construire tous
ensemble face à tous les dangers du
monde que nous venons juste d'évoquer
avant alors cette élection du 9 juin
2024 on ne laissera pas cela voler par
justement toutes les forces extrêmes
nous serons tous avec vous pleinement
mobilisés pour défendre ce projet
européen auquel nous croyons donc on
compte pleinement sur vous comme on
compte sur nos députés à l'échelle de
l'Assemblée nationale et c'est à mon
tour de donner la parole à notre
président de groupe Jean-Paul
matthi